let's learn a little bit about
centripetal acceleration so let's say i
have a dot that could be anything and
we're in deep space so we're not going
to think about gravity and all these
things yet but let's say i have some
object that's that's
floating through space with some
velocity let me draw the object so that
says this is this dot
and it has some velocity and i will draw
its velocity vector
let's say that this is it's i'll draw it
really big because i have i know that's
not big let me make a thicker line
whoops there you go thicker line
if you can see that
so let's say that's the dot's velocity
vector
and i have a question for you so this is
what the dot's doing at exactly this
moment let's say a little bit later i
want the dot to be doing something
like this i want its velocity vector to
look like
i want actually its velocity vector to
look like this
a little bit later
oh
and it's color changes to yellow
that's out of the scope color changing
is out of the scope of this lecture but
let's say a little bit later
i want its velocity vector
to look something like
that so i was a little careful because i
want to have the same magnitude but just
a little different direction i want it
to kind of tilt into the right a little
bit let me
draw that
and my question is what had to be the
acceleration acting when when this was
its velocity vector in order to get its
velocity vector to look like this a
little bit later
well right here its velocity vector is
completely in the x direction
right and there's no y component let's
break down this velocity's vector into
the x and y component
so its x component looks something like
this
and its y component looks something like
this
so in order to change its velocity
something would have had to
because clearly here it's y component
with zero there's no y component and now
there is a y component so the
acceleration that you would have to
apply to this dot
would have to have some y component
right the acceleration would have to
have some y component
so let's say that
and this is acceleration that's why it's
not the same size you might actually let
me draw acceleration in a different
color so it's
and i'll try to do this in a bunch of
different ways so you get the intuition
for it
i'm doing a slightly different blue
so you have to accelerate in the y
direction a bit and we don't know how
long but long enough to get its velocity
in the y direction this big
and then what would you have to
accelerate in the x direction
well your x component
shrinks a little bit right this was the
sex component now since you're tilted
down you get more y and less x
so what does the acceleration what
direction does the acceleration have to
go in to shrink
the
um
to shrink the x component
we have to go opposite right so you're
going to acceleration is going to go
that way a little bit and so if you were
to add these two vectors you would have
to accelerate something the acceleration
vector would look something like this
the acceleration vector would look
something like this
right
so what i'm i'm
and this might be a little confusing to
you but all i'm showing is is that i
want you to think about when and say an
object is traveling through space at a
constant velocity what does the
acceleration vector have to look like it
in order for that object to curve a
little bit
so for example if this was the let me
draw let's say this this object was here
right and if we had no force on it it
would just keep moving in this direction
would just you know its path would look
like this its path i'll draw the path
and brown its path would just look like
this it would be here then it would be
here a few seconds later it would just
keep going in the direction that it's at
and we know that from newton's law an
object in motion tends to stay in motion
and and the only way you can have a
change in velocity is if you have some
net force and some
net acceleration on the object
so in order for the object to curve in
order for the object's path to look
something like
this so here's the other path let's say
the object's path is like
this
and let's say it curves keeps curving
the object's path is like that and it
keeps curving so it goes there to there
then it's kind of going in a curved
motion what has to keep happening
well in order for the object's velocity
to go from this direction
right in the x direction
in order for its velocity to go from
this to go from this you have to
accelerate a little bit inwards right we
drew that right here you have to have
kind of an inward acceleration
and now it's velocity and then if you
did nothing else then the object will
just keep going in this direction
so in order to make it curve a little
more you gotta pull in a little bit
again so you have to have
and then and then if you don't pull it
again it'll just keep going in this
direction so you got to keep pulling
inwards on it you got to keep pulling
inwards on it
and i think you're starting to get a
sense of what i'm what i'm saying so if
you if if the object if you want the
object to go into a circle for example
there has to be a constant inward force
always pulling on the object
because if there isn't that concert in
so this is so the this whatever
off-white color this is when there's a
constant inward force the object's going
to travel in a circular path
right
if that inward force well one if that
inward force doesn't exist
let's say that that inward force is
there and then all of a sudden when the
object's here the inward force
disappears then the object's just going
to go in a straight line
tangent to the to the circular path
and that makes sense and i'll go into it
a little bit more detail in a second but
if you are spinning an object around in
a circle on a string
and the string is providing the inward
force and as soon as you let go of the
string
the object goes off in a straight line
and so that's what we're talking about
so what does this inward acceleration
have to actually before i go into
actually calculating what that inward
acceleration has to be let's think about
what happens if that inward acceleration
isn't enough or if it's too much
so i just said if if i have a let's say
this is like the center of our rotation
let's say this is where the inward force
is coming from
right there
and let's say this is my object let's
say it's a spaceship
that's my spaceship
there's fire coming out of it
and actually the fire would only go on
an impulse because once you have a
little fire coming out in space there's
no wind resistance so it'll keep just
going you don't have to keep some of
these these science fiction movies where
the the fire just keeps going um that
doesn't make sense you just have to have
an impulsive fire that would accelerate
you and then you wouldn't have to keep
showing the fire in the back of the
spaceship but anyway
maybe you realize that already or that's
out of the scope of this lecture but
let's say the
the object's velocity is like that
and i don't know let's say this is a
planet or some kind of weird force field
or something
if if this force field is kind of a weak
force field if this object is moving
really fast and this is a weak force
field that's always pulling in towards
it the object's path is going to look
something like this
it's going to look something like this
it's not going to be a circle it's kind
of kind of spiral outwards
right
if this is a really if so that's kind of
a weak inward force
if it's a really strong inward force the
object's path is going to look like this
and i'll do that in yellow
it's actually going to fall in
it's going to spiral into the object
and if it's just right given how far the
object is and i'll give you a formula
for what just right implies but if the
inward force is just right the object's
going to essentially orbit around this
object
it's going to go in a perfect circle its
path will be
like that
so let's think about what that inward
force has to be and we're not going to
well this could have been gravity this
inward force but uh
i won't work with the gravity yet
because gravity actually the force
changes depending on how close you get
to it so i won't i won't deal with
gravity yet but it could have been
anything it's a tractor beam
so let's try to get an intuition of
how how strong that inward force is and
what it what variables is it dependent
on
so let's say i have a
a let's say this is my hand
and i have a string
i have a string
and on that string i have a rock
and my question is if i want this rock
to spin it around in a circle and it'll
spin around in a perfect circle we've
all done this before
so if i want the rock
to spin around in that circle
what has to be the force that i pull on
on this string or essentially how much
does the inward acceleration have to be
on that rock so let's let's get an
intuition for maybe what what has to
happen
so think about it if the rock is moving
let's say right here at this point its
velocity looks something like this
at this point its velocity looks
something like this
and then when the rock is here
its velocity looks something like
this so to move from this velocity to
this velocity if this if the magnitude
is really big
it's i'm going to have to apply more
acceleration to change its direction
hopefully that makes a little sense
right to go from this velocity vector to
this velocity vector i have to up if if
this vector was even bigger if to say
this vector looked like this it had more
magnitude
i would have to pull inward with even
more force and accelerate inward at even
a higher rate
so definitely
the higher the velocity the more i'm
going to have to pull in and also the
higher the velocity the shorter the time
between this and this right this
object's moving around the circle
so there's kind of two components that
are affecting it on the velocity affects
the acceleration i need in two ways
actually i'm running out of time so i'll
continue this in the next video